can great to see you before we go into
the weeds of the deal itself explain
briefly why GKN is so important for the
UK corner well think about its assets
it's um one of the few remaining
high-tech engineering companies which is
still developing with very very large
R&D sort of programs and of course
rigidly placed in all sorts of
industries which are going to be
important going forward electric
vehicles and springs to mind so and of
course there is the sort of strategic
side for the UK it is a contributor to
production of components for Defence and
planes and and have a sort of assets
like that about 5,000 UK employees
absolutely yeah so today we've heard
that we've had the final offer from
Melrose so under the takeover code they
cannot raise their offer again unless a
counter bidder emerges that's right so
basically now we are they haven't have
there's been no review of the sort of
timeline so a still on course for that
29th of March an end of offer period and
after that they need to either put up or
shut up to use the sort of phrase and
that means they have to walk away I
think it's like six months or something
like that it's very unlikely that we're
going to see any sort of change and
relative to what we've seen today
now 467 pence that's the headline price
according to Melrose GKN is doubting
that because they say well that includes
the final dividend that we're paying and
also it's based off a higher Melrose
share price absolutely the case lutely
so so Melrose you could say they're not
exactly straining themselves they've
raised their offer but it's the raise
part is entirely inequity and of course
with the value of their equity falling
today by something like five percent
that reduces the sort of Vanden raised
part by some 20 pence so essentially I
think it was I mean it looks kind of
symbolic but it's obviously a little bit
more value there on the table
there certainly are trying to give the
message that they are really believed
that their offer was pretty much full as
it was and for people who don't know
Melrose I mean they're that they've been
accused we had a trade union activist on
a couple of weeks ago who said well
these guys are breakup merchants breakup
activist is is that fair and I think you
certainly politically there's a case we
made for
that but on the other hand you know I
think it is also true that they
certainly do invest hugely in the
companies are they that they sort of buy
they invest probably as much as they
have paid for purchase prices but their
business model simply wouldn't make
sense if they were just buying companies
and hold them for long term making no
changes at all
I mean they've made spectacular returns
for sure we should point out yes so what
happens next do you think now already
we've had GKN say they're gonna break
themselves up so this company is not
going to exist in its present form
regardless of indeed so what happens
next is that um I think it's a we have
until the turn another day of March
share for shareholders to decide that
they want to go with their Melrose s bid
or let it lapse and then of course
they'll the attention will move on to
the the offer from Donna in the US or
sort of agreement repetitively agreed to
uh sort of emerge the drive driveline
assets but I think what essentially is
on the table is reasonably good value
Jam today for slightly better Jam
tomorrow and of course that's you know
the darling incorporated them deal
depends on US regulators okaying yet and
their their shareholders are not going
to vote on it until the fourth quarter
of this year so it's a long time to wait
mathematically you've got to expect
shareholders to really go for what's on
the table more pointing out of course a
lot of GK ends existing shareholders
don't like the Donner deal because they
would receive shares in the US and they
may not necessarily be allowed to have
absolutely so you'll have some
institutional investors some overseas
investors which you know I think they
will be strictly prohibited from being
invested in US companies depending on
the sort of Reema's terms of articles
association for the you know an
institutional investor investing that
they have and then they have to sell up
anyway but you know really I think what
you have is really two great offers I
think really on the table right now one
of them has a longer timeline than the
other and one of them is a bit lesser
than the other
the melrose off
it may you know it's arguably arguably
on the values some of the synergy
synergy and assets that GKN has but it's
on the on the table right now and it's
there I mean essentially what people are
being asked to decide here is which of
the two management's do you prefer yes
while smell I mean the GKN argument is
that the Melrose management is pretty
untested in aerospace yes I mean I think
there is that there is that aspect but
they're they are very well tested in
some of the other industries they're
involved in and their bid certainly has
merits in terms of the sort of like the
structure of it going forward there's no
doubt that um they will run a very very
orderly ship there's no doubt that they
will have the capability to actually
invest and also to manage businesses
going forward and have synonyms is it do
you think that Aviva investors have come
out in favor of the Melrose bid today I
think it's quite significant isn't it
but again Aviva investors are speaking
in their capacity you know using their
fiduciary duty you know all boards have
a greater the interest they must have
the interests of investors at heart and
that's probably the most important
consideration for Aviva investors should
really be the most important
consideration for all management teams
really